merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur jean claude bouchet maire
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
nos agriculteurs et nos éleveurs
traverse une crise majeure et ce en
train de mourir ils n'ont d'autre choix
que d'être à nouveau dans la rue
aujourd'hui ce sont des éleveurs mais
demain ce sont les arboriculteurs les
maraîchers qui seront aussi dans la rue
pour être entendu cette crise qu'il
traverse n'a que trop duré le problème
est vaste avec des différences de charge
de norme de réseau de distribution de
prix etc tous touchés libyen est à
revoir
aujourd'hui monsieur le premier ministre
trouvez vous normal que ce soit
l'allemagne qui soit devenu à la place
de la france
le jardin de l'europe je relaie ici le
cri d'alarmé de ces hommes et de ces
femmes qui travaillent notre terre qui
nous nourrissent quotidiennement qui
entretiennent nos espaces
demain si rien ne change nous n'aurons
plus de ruralité à cette crise s'ajoute
des problèmes climatiques et
environnementaux qui oblige nos
agriculteurs à faire face à de nouvelles
menaces
je parle ici donc 800 ravageur appelé
communément en mouche de la cerise qui
sévissent sur nos vergers du sud de la
france et je rappelle à ce propos que le
vaucluse
mon département représentent plus de 30%
de la production nationale de cerises
pour endiguer ce fléau les
arboriculteurs ont pour seule arme le
diméthoate mais ce produit homologué est
prévue d'être interdite prochainement et
c'est ainsi toute la production de
cerises française qui est purement et
simplement menacés sachant que ce
ravageur commence à s'étendre aussi à la
vigne or certains pays européens je
pense à l'italie à la grèce on choisir
d'en maintenir l' usage alors monsieur
le premier ministre
cela ne vous pose est il pas de problème
de laisser sacrifier notre production au
bénéfice d'autres pays européens
notre agriculture est en train de mourir
d'être la meilleure élève de l'europe
celle qui respecte le mieux les normes
notre ruralité disparaît comment pouvez
vous accepter cela merci la parole étant
monsieur stéphane le foll ministres
agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt c'est le président monsieur le
député vous avez évoqué une question
spécifique d'une mouche que vous n'avez
pas nommer qui s'appelle la drosophile
suzuki c'est pour l'information de tous
les parlementaires
il se trouve que l'an dernier dans un
visite dans le vaucluse
nous avons évolué au placebo de les
mouches qui s'attaquent effectivement à
l'église et aussi aux olives et qu'il y
a un produit qui s'appelle diméthoate
qui est utilisé et j'avais trouvé un
accord qui permettait de diminuer les
doses et d'avoir des limites maximales
d'utilisation avant la vente qui avait
trouvé l'accord entre le ministre
l'agriculture et les arboriculteurs à
partir de cette question s'est posée
suite à une enquête et un rapport de
l'ansès à nouveau la question de ceux
des métaux ap substances dangereuses et
qui nécessite qu'on réévalue son
utilisation
il ya une réunion au ministère de
l'agriculture et semaine dernière pour
réévaluer cette question il se trouve
que l'entreprise qui produit ce produit
de diméthoate n'a pas souhaité redéposer
un dossier pour qu'on puisse réguliers
sur la base de ce qui sera proposé par
l'entreprise les conditions
d'utilisation de ce diméthoate je ferai
tout monsieur le député pour faire en
sorte qu'on trouve des solutions en
particulier avec des engagements
collectifs au niveau de la production et
aussi des alternatives voir si
l'entreprise peut déposer son dossier
voir la playmate qu'à la manière dont on
pourra utiliser en toute sécurité ce
produit pour que continue la production
de cerises et d'olives en france